so today we're taking a do you think
these examples of micro cheating are
actually cheating cheating two words
back-to-back we already know that's the
problem that sounds naughty cheating
cheating like are you telling the truth
the truth exactly exactly
I actually don't know what your thoughts
are on like what is considered cheating
honestly I've never asked you so good
let's do it in front of let's do it
following a bunch of hot people
Instagram influencers models on social
media and liking all their posts you're
gonna follow people that you find
attractive on social that means you'd be
doing that you I'm just saying in
general really wow you're attractive I'm
gonna take a picture this is a nice
picture but the word gets fishiness
question is what it says making all of
their posts can't go of a certain
percentage of liking is that where I am
if they have a hundred pictures that you
like ninety nine of them I'm sorry
that's a problem but fifty eight is cool
no I mean I definitely wouldn't like to
see that you do that yeah it's not
cheating no it just means that you're
you're a ho-bag I don't think that's
cheating staying actively in touch with
an egg's no I don't think it's cheating
if you're actively in touch or someone
I'm friends with all my exes and that's
fine
give them their names now yeah I like it
was friends of them and I would
literally I would literally never in a
million years yeah go back to them yeah
I'm friends with exes staying actively
in touch with Max absolutely not gonna
play with me don't try it not this
lifetime that's lifetim seven lifetimes
from out I don't even care if I die do
not cuz I will haunt you come I stood
you up at prom you think I don't
actually know I had a Greek confiding in
someone you're attracted to instead of
talking to your significant other that's
how they'd be getting in through the
back door and they'd be like oh yeah he
did what he don't cook for you yeah
here's some spaghetti I just made yeah
eat that yeah you know I'm saying to be
trying to butter you up and then trying
to utilize all the stuff you're not
getting from your significant other
right now it's still not cheating but
it's not great I don't think it's right
yeah the attraction thing makes
uncomfortable now it's not cheating I'd
say yeah I don't think it's right you
want me talking to somebody about us
that I that I think it's a trap no but
is it cheating no it's not cheating
purposefully neglecting to mention you
have an Esso to an attractive person
it's not cheating it's not fine either
so not sure but it's a little sauce
would be my responses oh yeah me too I
think I feel like we just keep picking
the middle ground and all of these you
know what back in the day I used to do
that but not purposely what you mean
like I would just not say something that
when I was in college whatever like if I
was like old girls cute you know I just
wouldn't say that I had a girlfriend
unless it came up in conversation why
unless it came up in conversation and
she would ask and then which I would
still not say it
so now that I'm mature I see that that's
wrong so for like the past like my
grown-up years I always you know throw
that in the conversation but not weirdly
though you can't do it you know too soon
I might say good morning I have somebody
come on you're all over me
it's like it should be like that no you
should yeah Julie some people would
think I was a crazy person if you are in
the store you are an aisle and someone
says excuse me because they're sure to
get to the apples you need to turn
around and say I have a beautiful
girlfriend okay I'm not gonna go yeah
I'm not gonna look crazy for you you
should really that's what you're doing
you get about Sam boy so to do is that
you like in the picture they do they
know that Carly and chatting with
someone you're attracted to late at
night who is he a significant other
Naomi I throw this these equations for
people who got one foot in and one foot
out to see their moral compass yeah
we're good people man we got we're here
yeah we're good people I mean that's
like on the borderline of me wondering
if we should break up yeah I don't even
call and chat to you late at night I
know it's a point of contention off
tagging someone you're attracted to an
inside-joke means you can be attracted
to someone but not want to do anything
about it because you're in love with
someone else
you're enough with your partner yeah
you're already attracted other people it
doesn't mean you want to act on it as
far as fine
this actually makes me more mad I know
why you're gonna hate connection it's
like inside jokes like why have inside
jokes with someone you're attracted and
what do y'all doing is out of there
I don't think it's cheating though right
but I just think it's saying this is not
it's cheating's cousin swim around
frolicking sex and someone other than
your significant other but never
actually having sex with them cheating I
don't care about nobody says you know
what if a girl does it it's really bad
cuz that means she really like them like
girls get invested on emotional level if
a guy's sexing it's like okay you're
just like somebody touch on three or
four it's cheating I would probably call
this G yeah I think this is cheating
yeah because sexting is that you have
the intent to do something behind it and
it's something like you don't have to
physically get up once because you said
get up on someone for it to be cheating
I think because if you're like that
close to doing it but yeah very very
very open on what I expect out of my
relationship and you know habits and how
people behave so I think that we already
we know this stuff and we know each
other the right thing we did so good no
we did I think we did good mainly
because we have common sense I think we
did great I think that we agreed on
everything and we're the perfect couple
in all the land
what could go wrong no I thought we did
great yeah we actually agreed on all of
it yeah
late at night what you think they talk
about late at night oh yeah how are you
tonight Wow I lifted so many weights and
put them back down and then I picked
them up a game you must have been so
sweaty
then I pop in through the door [ __ ]